i knew you had the packer connection
yeah yet another reason for us to not do
a podcasting right because you're
here we are my boyfriend's collarbone
yes and i'm rooting never for you i'm so
sorry
i believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and i want to help give you the tools to
make that
happen i'm danica patrick and i'm pretty
intense
today is the very very brave
gretchen carlson she's a journalist
a whistleblower and an empowerment
advocate
the things that she's doing nowadays to
change the laws to give women more of a
voice
are brave and important
her bravery is changing the face of
culture
but what you didn't know is that she was
a prodigy
violinist she was miss
america and of course then she went on
to
be on television and become a household
name gretchen's a wonderful great girl
and i hope you enjoy this episode
are you a vikings fan oh my gosh yes you
love football right oh my god
football is your favorite football is my
favorite sport i still put on my jersey
and my
tennis shoes that are purple on sundays
just even if i can't watch the game
just to be able to be there in spirit
and i'm constantly tweeting out what the
score is and then you know our hashtag
is skull
s-k-o-l why which is because it's
scandinavian and we're vikings and i'm
scandinavia
are you uh so i'm norwegian so are you
norwegian
i'm swedish oh you're swedish okay yes
so we're not supposed to like each other
actually
oh that's a bummer just growing up in
minnesota my grandparents used to speak
swedish when they didn't want the
grandkids to
know what they were talking about so i
vowed i was gonna learn how to speak
swedish and anyway my grandfather was
very much a humorist and he told jokes
all the time and
so when you're swedish the butt of the
jokes were the norwegians so sorry about
that
yeah but we can change it so that we can
at least do this podcast
yeah i think we need to unify yeah but
i'm not but i'm a huge vikings are
scandinavians scandinavians yes but the
the interesting thing is with my
children
um especially my my son who you know is
a huge football fan as well
you have two kids right yes my
daughter's 16 now my son's 14.
but he'll be rooting for like the new
york giants and i'm like what are you
doing and i'm like oh yeah he lives here
he was born here
and i was like it's like my whole idea
of being the minnesota fan didn't
transfer over
but the the interesting thing is my
husband was a vikings fan
as um a child because he grew up in
columbus ohio and they didn't really
have a team
yeah yeah so he could have been
cleveland brown friend or cincinnati
bengals but he chose the vikings so
maybe is he a big college fan then
oh yeah michigan the ohio state no he
was he was
he was a um trader of sorts because he
got a baseball scholarship to michigan
and so he yes he crossed over the line
and and he takes my son to the michigan
ohio state game
every every year in michigan or either
one
either one yes and they wear their blue
and yellow well i had a defying moment
where i
because i grew up near chicago and so i
was a bears fan all my life but of
course now i'm dating the quarterback
for the packers so i'm an actress fan
and i have a place downtown chicago and
so my girlfriends and i went there for
the first game of the year it was
actually the first game of the nfl
season
and we went to breakfast and at
breakfast
more people had packers clothes on than
bears and we were in chicago
yes and so at that point time we
realized
okay let's all put our gear on and we
walked around town
all day that day before the game in our
packers clothes
and you know people were really nice
they were really nice like hey will you
take a picture for us like yeah sure i
thought for sure they'd be like
throwing stones at us and that's till
they get drunk at the game
and then they're throwing spit balls at
you or something or something worse but
yes i knew you had the packer connection
yeah yet another reason
for us to not do a podcasting right
because you're
yes and i'm rooting never for you i'm so
sorry
so it's really nice to meet you for
coming i know i know but but he's a
great quarterback i will give you that
much i mean i
admire of talent that is a common theme
yes he's he's very he's very gifted um i
just don't like it when he beats us
yeah well so we'll see one down one to
go this year so wait a minute the
packers
they sandra seven
the chargers beat them yes they're seven
and two now
and uh but i know that one of the games
that was really like
one of them that he put a lot of thought
to as far as you know how
it normally goes and worried about is he
was worried about playing the vikings
yes and um and we beat him so
uh so don't worry don't we again this at
the end of the year
we go to minnesota yes so do you ever go
to games
um yes in fact so the vikings were
playing the giants
this year in new york oh yeah and um
i unfortunately had a speech on that
afternoon melissa
sunday i know sunday at one o'clock and
so my son of course said to me
mom if the giants win
can i get a giant's jersey and i said
okay and then he goes and if the vikings
win can i get a giant
and what does mom get out of this and so
when the vikings won
after my speech i was texting him and
he's like
when can i have my jersey like okay all
right
yeah so we have this little rivalry
that's going on but i don't get to
minnesota that much to the
to the games because i tend to like go
to go visit minnesota in the summertime
yeah yeah which means that's the state
bird which is the
mosquito well yes yes the real one is
the loon but the
mosquito but it's better oh what's the
loon the minnesota loon
yeah um i just saw one actually speaking
of being there in the summer time
they're beautiful that they're um it's a
beautiful sort of thin bird with a
very long beak but it's it's known for
its
um hoot sound that it makes so
you can tell a loon because it's like
kind of like an owl
is that actually the statement it is
actually the safer yes not the made up
one which is the mosquito
i remember being up north so my my mom's
side of the family actually my mom was
born in minnesota
she was born right up on the state like
north of bemidji all the way up to
canada
actually almost all of her family except
for one she's one of five lives in
canada
and uh there was the horse flies
like crazy all over the place remember
there was a little that we'd go up to
their lake house my
and one of my and one of my uncles or
aunts
and uh we tried i remember going down by
the water and we just ran right back
as kids because you were just getting
pummeled
with horse flies from the water being
soaked right there
um but yeah there's a lot of nature
there but what else do you what do you
remember about growing up in
minnesota and what do you love and what
are you so glad that you don't have to
deal with anymore
um the snow i od on snow so that's why i
don't take my kids to visit
usually in the winter time in minnesota
it also you know didn't help the whole
mission when i went to school in
california i went to stanford
so then i you know it's like february
studying under a palm tree
with shorts on so that sort of got me
off the whole snow thing
but listen i i loved where i grew up
minnesota is
an amazing place with amazing people um
the values and what i like to call now
the midwestern sensibilities like i'm
still incredibly frugal
um that came from like appreciating the
value of a dollar
i remember asking my dad one time if i
could go bowling with my friends because
we had a bowling alley just up the
street from us on the highway
and he was like well no because we can't
afford it and i was like
dad it's a dollar and he's like nope he
goes you have to understand the value of
a dollar if you want to go bowling then
you'll have to like sweep the floor
before you go and then you can earn the
money to be able to go
wow and this is the way in which i was
raised with these
you know sensibilities and i remember
cutting coupons
for my mom before she would go to the to
the grocery store
um there's still a real serious frugal
side to me i'm not a shopper um
[Music]
if you put me in a store then i'll i'll
look at stuff and i'll be like oh yeah i
need that and i need that
but for me to like actually go out and
go shopping it's
not in my dna what's your favorite
splurge though
um shoes okay well those are great they
kind of look gucci i don't know what
they are but
um they're they're very much on sale
valentino which is very out of the
ordinary
for me um but shoes are sailor the
valentino
um valentino yeah no everything's always
on sale for me
ever you know you just gotta wait for
that right moment like to buy it at the
top price no way
uh but so you don't use the girl
justification of when it's on sale
you're saving money you're like no
that's just when it's the right price
well i i just can't bring myself to pay
full price for something
like you know expensive shoes but shoes
have always been my
splurge because i think being in
television uh i always sort of had to
wear an outfit
like a uniform yeah which was like a a
a dress that was all you know one nice
bright color
yeah and so the only way you could
really show your personality was either
through your earrings or
through your shoes and so shoes sort of
became the thing for me where i like to
show
personality um so anyway being frugal in
minnesota and just
you know minnesota has this phrase
minnesota nice
and the biggest compliment somebody can
give to me still to this day
is that you are still the same authentic
real
little girl from small town minnesota
that you were when i knew you way back
when
and that to me just still is
like i said the greatest compliment
somebody can give me because
we can all go on to achieve you know
great things and work really hard and
live in a bunch of different places
but to really be true to yourself and to
who you are it's
to never really change and treat people
is that what you attribute
your reasoning for how you don't change
is that
you are true to yourself yes
and being authentic and my dad used to
always say to me
you know people will know who you are by
your actions not your words
and that is just so
true about being a real person and being
authentic
you can always tell somebody who's kind
of faking it and
so that that has actually been a central
part of my
life as a human being outside of my
career but also in my career
as a journalist where i'm constantly
meeting people and asking people
questions
the most important thing is to have it
not be about you
it's about listening to the person that
you're actually asking the questions of
and um and so you know my upbringing
really plays out in my life in so many
different ways
and as a mom oh my gosh i'm trying to
give those same midwestern sensibilities
to my kids
raising them outside of new york city
and that can be that can be a challenge
i would say that my husband and i
believe that
teaching our kids humility is the most
important
thing in in raising them and it's
precisely why i bring them back to
minnesota at least once a year every
year
because i want them to see how i grew up
and
what family life was really about and
the more simple life
and they love it they love being away
from sort of the fast-paced
you know new york upbringing what can
you do in the city then because there's
a lot of people
that are going to listen or watch this
and think i don't i don't live in a
small town
i'm like you i live in the city and i
don't even have family in minnesota to
go give them these values
so what do you try and do with them here
where things are so much busier and
there is so much more stimulus
and it's not that slower pace it's not
that
it's not nature it's you know go go go
and
concrete jungle yeah well go on vacation
to minnesota
i mean or canada we brought our kids to
canada this summer as well
uh i think that you know starbucks is
sort of my barometer about how we live
our lives
starbucks stay with me stay with me so
you know in new york when you order your
starbucks it has to appear like this
right or in la same thing but when you
go to minnesota or you go to any other
you know state in the middle of the
country it can take you five six to
seven minutes to get your starbucks
and at first when that started happening
to me i was like oh gosh
got all uptight and like what's taking
them so long and then i realized
this is emblematic of how people in the
whole middle part of the country
live their lives in a much less harried
hectic pace they maybe they're having
more conversation and face-to-face
interaction instead of being so worried
about just getting to the next place and
so
yes my barometer is how quickly it takes
you to get your starbucks
now if it took five to seven minutes in
new york city to get your starbucks
that would not go over very well so you
know i really encourage
people no matter where they live to kind
of just take a step back and
and realize that things don't have to be
so frenetic
um and really having those face-to-face
interactions especially with our kids in
the social media age and everything
their screen and their phone you know
and my mom has a rule actually when we
all get together
she makes all the kids not have their
phones at the dinner table that's great
which you know at first they're like
grandma you know takes a big huge
problem and she's like nope not at my
table yeah
and she you know sort of sort of forces
what i'm talking about this
old-school way of having face-to-face
conversations and interactions and you
know what after a while they don't
they don't miss it and we're like
playing bingo
and making s'mores and um
just having talks and so
so that's what my husband and i feel is
like the greatest challenge for us
is is raising our kids with humility and
with the ability to just
take a step back and not be so harried
what kind of activities do they like to
do
well they both love sports so my husband
and i have this yin and yang so
i um i love sports and i was athletic
however
all of my sports careers or endeavors
came to a halting screeching stop
because i was a very serious musician
yeah you played the violin yeah which is
kind of where i'm trying to get to is
like
what did that you know how did that play
into your life because you were
you were like a prodigy violinist you
were you were
you could still be playing the violin
today and i'm kind of curious if you
can't still play the violin no
i don't it's a big long story but but
this is why i could my mom made me quit
sports eventually because my fingers
were like my
entire livelihood and and i broke this
pinky finger playing football with my
brothers in
sixth grade and she was like that's it
you know no more sports for you other
than like tennis
um where you can and this is also why i
don't cook until recently because
honestly they didn't let me touch knives
what because it you know my fingers were
especially my
left hand was just essential to what was
supposed to be my
career so you asked about my kids so my
kids have the music
bug um and they also have the sports bug
from my
husband now when we got when we started
dating
i said to him well you already you know
got kind of the jackpot because i
already love sports
so are you going to now figure out
classical music so that we can
go to concerts together and all this and
that um let's see it's almost 22 years
and that has not happened
oh i know but my kids kind of have an
appreciation for
for both but i don't make them practice
at all like um
like i had to do what do they play do
they they play piano okay
and my son played trumpet for a little
while my daughter actually asked me if
she could play
the violin early on and i kind of um
i'm going to tell a little lie here to
her and and
the real story to you is that i i told
her you know that that would not be a
good idea
and the reason is because i didn't want
to emotionally go through it
um because it's really really really
hard for me
now because i don't play anymore and
i didn't want to have like a mini me and
expectations of
her having to play the violin at the
same kind of level that that i was
so we just kind of didn't go down that
path
and they both do do piano my daughter's
probably a little more serious about it
than my son
but if i can get 20 to 30 minutes out of
them a day that's a lot
as opposed to the four hours a day i was
putting in
so were you afraid that your
level of knowledge and your own
commitment to the violin was going to
play a part in what you saw in her
and her level of commitment and and and
if you saw something you could help her
with
were you worried you were going to be
compelled to fix everything because you
knew how and you wanted to i just didn't
want to
want her to have the same expectations
that i
that i had you know were they your
expectations though or were they your
families well they were both
early on it was minds because i think
when you're a kid and you start
doing something that that you're good at
and that you realize early on that
putting time into it you get
better at that builds immense self
confidence and discipline so that was
really wonderful so i wanted to do it
because i saw myself getting getting
better and i was such a competitive
child that
that perfectly suited my personality
but then when i got to be like a
teenager there were all these
distractions
you know there were boys and there was
school and there was i wanted to try out
for the play and
there were just so many different things
out there and i didn't really want to
invest all that time in just one thing
and then
start got into that little rebellious
mode with my parents
where they're like wait a minute you
invested all this time
we sort of feel like we owe it to you as
your parents to make sure that you
continue down this path and they were
not stage parents by any stretch of the
imagination they just
you know i grew up with them telling me
you can be anything you want to be in
this world it's going to take a lot of
hard work
and we expect you to put in the hard
work
and i don't i did not
necessarily want my daughter to feel
like she only
had to do one thing in life and add to
that kids are so much more busy now than
than we were growing up i mean they now
you have to like dedicate yourself to a
sport
early on you have to pay it play it all
seasons long you know
school club you name it like exactly and
then this
coaching outside of school it's crazy um
and then just the amount of schoolwork
that kids have now oh really is
oh my gosh it's so above and beyond what
i had
and i was a good student so i was
putting in a lot of time to study
but my daughter as a junior
has like six hours of homework a night
it's crazy like i'm not even feasible it
almost isn't
and so where did where would she have
four extra hours to be practicing the
piano
so which one do you think would be
better for her
i just wish there was more of a balance
because
i think we put so much pressure on our
on our young people
especially where she is right now junior
year there's just so much that collapses
on you you're starting to
you learn how to drive you get your
driver's license you you start looking
at colleges you start taking the act or
the sat
plus junior year is the most rigorous
for
academics and so we just like dump all
this pressure
on a 16 year old and say hey figure it
out and oh by the way
on the side you're going to do sports
and you're going to practice your piano
right
yeah you're trying to go to church and
you're going to you know do volunteer
service
and it's just it's it's a lot and and i
can say that because i had a lot on my
plate too as a kid and i don't think i
would have been able to do all of it now
in in 2019 you were accepted to
juilliard school which is that
where it's in new york city um but you
ended up going to stanford
you're just such a so accomplished i
mean it's impressive
um and then we'll get to the next part
which is being miss america
but uh so why did you decide to go to
stanford
and um so this was part of my rebellious
moment juilliard would have been about
playing the violin right
yes because it's an art school yes um it
is
and so my goal in life when i was a kid
and playing the violin that seriously
was that one day i wanted to perform in
carnegie hall which is also here in new
york city
the irony is my very first apartment in
new york city i could see carnegie hall
from my window
except i wasn't playing the violin
anymore um and ironic how life
kind of works out it is so weird and
then uh juilliard was like a hop skip
and a jump from my second apartment
um on the upper west side interesting
but i so my parents tried to find a
happy medium for me because
if i if i really what they probably
should have done if it was going to be
my career was having me move to new york
city when i was
10 or 11 or 12 years old but they
decided that they wanted to keep me in
minnesota have more of a
you know regular upbringing or one that
they were used to
are you glad yeah no i'm very grateful
for that and so what they did was
occasionally they
i came here to have lessons with the
premier teacher at juilliard
and then i went away all summer long to
the aspen music festival
from age 10 on for nine weeks where i
had intense training with all the
juilliard teachers who
who transferred out there so it was sort
of this nice
compromise i mean i gave up all my
summers but at least i could
stay in minnesota as a as a child yeah
so when it came to turning 17 years old
that's when i told my parents i was
quitting
how did you arrive at that conclusion i
just um
it wasn't like an overnight decision it
it built up over
a couple of years a couple of things
i expressed earlier that i was just
interested in so many other things
and i realized that to be the best in
the world of violin i would have to give
up
everything else in my life yeah and i
wasn't sure that i
wanted to do that and another huge
aspect of it
was that i had seen a lot of musicians
who didn't seem happy to me and
i was always a really happy good-natured
you know humorous little kid and a good
western girl
it pained me to think that i would
choose a career where maybe i wouldn't
be
happy and especially with the tunnel
vision aspect of it
where once you go down that path then
you're pretty much giving up everything
else
and so i told my parents i was going to
quit it was quite devastating for them
did you love playing the violin i did
but it then it you know it just became
um it just kind of got in the way of
other things that i
that i wanted to do even academics you
know i was a really good student but
it was like okay are you going to
practice the violin that that extra hour
are you going to study
and um so
i quit much to the chagrin of my parents
who were how'd they handle it
they were devastated it was you know not
necessarily for the
monetary commitment they had put into my
lessons and all of that it was more that
they
felt like one day i would regret it
and that is exactly how i got into the
whole miss america system
i mean it was it was it was completely
because of my violin
how because so i quit and i went i went
off to stanford and concentrated on my
academics and i did take my violin with
me just to pacify my parents and then i
promptly put it in the locker in the
music school and never took it out i was
gonna say did you have some sort of like
uh
guitar crushing like how you picture
guitar getting smashed did you have some
kind of ceremony
violins are worth too much to do that
how much is a violin
oh my god like ones that ones that you
played um
i mean sixty to a hundred thousand
dollars
what yes but no but listen stradivarius
are millions and millions of dollars
what
so and i actually had an opportunity to
play a stradivarius at stanford
and i still didn't even play it that
goes to show you how determined i was to
try and move away from this
you know this part of my life so so yes
and violins are like wines they get
better with age i was gonna say there's
and so it feels like wine like how much
is that bottle of petrus you know and
you're like is it really that much
better
yeah and and the amazing thing not to
get off on another tangent but
the amazing thing is that they've never
been able to really mimic
how they made how the italians made the
violins in the 16 1700s
oh so they're that old oh yeah okay so
they don't make those and oh my gosh
stratovarius no because stradivarius
died so he
so the the violence is a guy yes okay
he's a violin maker
and they're the most famous violins in
in the world and they're
they're they're actually owned by
museums or
very wealthy people and then they allow
gifted people to play them because
here's the other really interesting
thing about violins you have to play
them to keep them up
you can't just put them in your closet
and and um
you know have them sound the same way
five years later you have to continue to
to play them so anyway i i didn't do
that
i put the violin in the in the locker do
you wish you would have played the
stradivarius um i have i have played a
stradivarius
um since that okay that's good but even
that even that was not a hook for me to
go back
to it so what did you love about it
what did i love about the violence yeah
oh my gosh um
like the accomplishment of putting you
understand this from putting
time into something and getting better
at it and
and the most crucial thing about it was
that it was something nobody could ever
take away from me
ever and that i think especially in
being women is
so important that um
it was a power thing you know it was
like i'm good at this
this is my talent and you can't take it
from me and
um that gave me the discipline in life
to achieve everything else you know
people say to me well what's
similar about the your television career
the violin and i say everything
because it taught me that discipline of
how i approach
every day and how i that fire in my
belly to be the best that i can be
and the competitive spirit and
um and the performance aspect i mean
going on stage and playing the violin or
driving in a race is the same feeling is
as going out in front of the camera and
seeing the red light
go on you know it's that comfort zone
it's the rush and the comfort zone
because i've
been doing that since i'm six years old
so
you know those things will never leave
me and in fact i can still see all the
notes in my head i just can't play them
so it's not like riding a bike you lose
it you know my
you lose your fingers and your can you
play it all um
yes but i would never play for anyone
else right now
on occasion i'll play when nobody else
is in the house
and i even look at my dog and don't tell
anybody
don't tell anybody how much i suck why
wouldn't no i i
i actually would venture to say that you
probably
are very good at it no not not i'll
never be like i was at 14. well of
course not you you're
doing it every day i know but that's the
painful aspect of it why i don't do it
and i i really why do you hold yourself
to that standard because
i think who cares than you i know but
when you've been
to that level and you know the time and
the energy
that it took to to get to that level
and to not be able to do that is very
sad to me
it's um like like i said
my brain can still see all the notes but
my fingers can't keep
up so anyway
my dad would love if i went back to it i
should yeah but this is interesting
because it kind of reminds me of my
career which was
i didn't actually love racing yeah like
i don't know if this is true i don't
know if you didn't love
playing the violin but if you just love
playing the violin you just play it for
fun
maybe because i don't like i just i love
the challenge
i loved setting a goal and achieving it
that was what drove me which is
something that you pretty much
said earlier and it wasn't the driving
and that's how i was able to leave it
behind and
let go of it and move on because it
wasn't about the driving
like i don't want to go hit the track
and just pound around by myself
maybe similarly to what you don't want
to just play because you're like that
wasn't
it that wasn't what i loved about it
um partially but i did i did love
the end product that i was able to emote
you know and the emotion that went into
it and the
the um it's such an individualistic
thing the way in which you interpret a
concerto like
that is so personal and so i did
love that part of it um it just became
a too many other distractions in my life
you know
and you became miss america well but
that's but so so to that story
which is when did that start so college
so you obviously went to college you
went to stanford
where did you at what point in time did
you start participating in pageants
um so i had done one
teen wasn't even really a pageant it was
a
um a teen competition that was based on
your grades
your volunteer service your talent your
interview
and then you put on an evening gown for
the end of the night
but um you're shoeing that was well and
i told
nobody i was doing it and then so um
that was my parents first way to try and
get me to still play the violin
and then so i ended up becoming first
runner up
nationally and that actually irked me
because i was got that close
and i was like okay you know
what happened like it would have been
better if i was like 10th or something
like what happened that i got that close
and you know it just didn't
so that sort of sat in in me
um percolating and then when i i spent
part of my junior year of college
studying over at oxford and my mom
called me up she said
i got this brochure in the mail and it's
about the miss america competition
and it says 50 5-0 percent of your
points are based on talent in this
competition
and you have that and i think you should
do this and i said mom
are you nuts well
i said i'm a tomboy i struggled with my
weight my whole life
um violin has never won
miss america i'm from minnesota which is
not thought of as a pageant state and by
the way i'm short
and by the way i'm not only just in some
town in america called oxford i'm in
england right
right and i'm studying our way and i
wanted to stay for a summer program that
i had worked my full head off to get
into
and she was telling me now oh just
rescind that offer
and come home and enter the first tier
of competition i really wanted you to
play the violin
they did and they believed in you and
she believed in me
and so i even after i told her all those
negative reasons why i shouldn't do it
she said i don't care
i believe in you and i think that you
should do this
my mom's really been inspirational and
influential in my
life she's been my biggest supporter and
my biggest critic
and so i came home and that's
exactly how it happened and then i
entered the the first
competition that summer and then um that
made me eligible to enter the state
competition so i went back to stanford
for a quarter and then i realized
if i'm really gonna go gain busters for
this thing
then i can't stay at stanford and try to
get to the level of competition that i
need to be i mean i had to go back to
practicing the violin in a really
incredibly serious way
and so i dropped out of what were you
studying at stanford
i was studying a bunch of things i mean
it's sort of the story of my life i
couldn't decide on a major
and so i ended up self-designing my
major in organizational behavior
if i had used it i would have been uh
like a corporate consultant like a
problem solver and i was my intention
was to go on to law school
and so the whole miss america thing so
then i dropped out of school and went
back home to prepare and then um
[Music]
and then ended up being miss minnesota
and then just three months later was the
national competition which is what i
i knew like so that's why i was plotting
ahead like okay well if it would happen
to work out in minnesota i won't have
enough time to prepare
for the national competition with only
three months so that i was kind of
working backwards realizing i had to
leave stanford
and again i told nobody when i went to
the female dean to tell her that i was
stopping out which was what we called it
she was like why are you stopping out of
stanford in your is that dropping out is
that basically like the casual
like that's the professional way of
taking a break and you know stopping out
so you can come back yes and she looked
at me and she said
what are you gonna do and i said um i'm
gonna try and become miss america and
she was like are you nuts that's the
craziest thing i've ever heard in my
life the dumbest thing she might have
said
so i told nobody and
went home and and really just um what
does preparation for
miss america look like well practicing
the violin again ridiculous amount of
hours a day
wow um researching every possible
news item and you know doing a ton of
mock interviews because
is that what got you into news well kind
of in a weird way because 30
of my score was interview 50 was talent
and then of course i had to kill myself
to get into shape because
as i said i struggled with my weight my
whole life and
so i was doing ridiculous workouts
and um you know i knew i was never going
to
win the swimsuit competition by any
stretch of the imagination but i had to
be competitive
i couldn't get a zero even though it was
only 10 of the score
so i had to work really you know really
hard and i hearkened back to the
discipline that i had in my life from
from my music so anyway um that just you
know it happened to all work out it's
the toughest job i've ever had i mean
you're
really yeah you're on you're on call
like
24 7 to have to be
[Music]
on basically and giving
big speeches in front of people that are
much wiser and older than you
and it is how i got into television
because the first week that i was miss
america they put me on this television
show you're probably too young to
remember it but it was called
bloopers and practical jokes with ed
mcmahon and dick clark
and so they were playing a practical
joke on me and
they were having me talk about a
satellite system that i knew nothing
about in front of 5000 engineers but
there were other people on the stage
with me so they said you don't have to
know anything about it it's fine
which was not my nature at all i was i
was asking a lot of questions
and so of course they start the whole
thing
and then one by one all the people on
the stage get called off the stage
their mic didn't work they had an
emergency phone call and all of a sudden
i'm the only one left on stage with this
satellite system
and the floor director goes oh my god
we're coming to you live early
in five four three [ __ ] two just start
talking
so i'm thinking i'm addressing 5 000
engineers about a satellite system i
know nothing about
and i start giving my little miss
america spiel that i've known
for about a week you know hi i'm
gretchen carlson and i'm so honored to
be here today and
blah blah blah and i stopped talking
after about a minute and he goes
oh no you have 13 more minutes to fill i
went
what and so i started just
talking about a satellite system that i
knew nothing about and they had all
these cue cards and every word was 14
letters long
they dropped them on the floor and then
i was reading them upside down
on the floor and i'm thinking the whole
time i'm doing this they're going to
fire me from this job
and six months later this silly show
aired
and did they tell you immediately after
did you not find out
after 14 minutes of hell they came back
on the stage and i pressed the button
and they said
gretchen you've been on bloopers and
practical jokes
what did you learn about yourself in
that 14 minutes that i could do anything
that was really painful experience of my
life like
being on a platform where i wasn't
prepared
that was just so not me and to have to
pull the rabbit out of the hat and and
make up stuff like that
so when it aired a couple tv agents saw
it and i was so embarrassed i was in a
hotel room with like the covers over my
eyes by myself and i was embarrassed of
myself
sitting there watching this thing like
humiliated and then
the phone rang and they were like if you
can do that
you can do tv and that's how i got into
tv
how where did you learn to hold yourself
to um
such a high standard i think it was the
way that i was raised with
parents who believed in me but also i
think
a lot of that is innate
because sometimes i wish i could turn it
off
the fire in my belly and the brain that
never stops
is it can be a positive but it can also
be a negative
what does failure look like and what
would that feel like to you oh i've had
a ton of failure i think it's actually
really important to admit our failures
and talk openly about them
and i can say that because i didn't talk
about one of my biggest failures for
a ton of years which was getting fired
from my job when i was well into my
prime and i had just gotten married
and a week after my honeymoon i was
fired and told that i would be fine now
that i had a husband
yes and i um had been part of a
two female local news team
which we were the first in the country
to be two females doing prime time
newscasts so it was very provocative
and progressive and it didn't work and
the other woman was
from cleveland so she was sort of like
the hometown hero
and sweetheart and so i was the logical
one to go
and i didn't do anything wrong but it
didn't feel good
and i you know being married in that
transition was tough enough
and i was in my 30s already and
established in my career and i was just
so incredibly embarrassed
and i mean i remember reading the
headlines like of course they all
went back to the miss america thing and
like you know bye-bye miss america i
remember that song
and that was the headline in the
newspaper and i remember sitting in the
bathroom and just sobbing
because getting fired is such a lonely
experience and such a humiliating
experience and um and i knew in my heart
that to get another job in television i
was gonna have to move and i just got
married
so there was a tremendous amount of
pressure on me of failure and then also
like how soon after miss america was
that
this was years after i was 22 when i was
miss america so then i you know
my first job was in richmond virginia
then i went to cincinnati then i went to
cleveland
while i was in cleveland i met my
husband on a blind date and i was
promoted to this main anchor
role and then we got married and then i
was fired
so i was out of work for
the first full year of our marriage i'm
sure i was wonderful to live with
wow for such a high achiever
and now you're put into a dynamic with a
partner where
we're not competitive with our partner
but we want to pull our weight right and
we want to
be worth something and be of value and
um that had i mean what did um
how did your how did your husband handle
well i'm sure it was not
fun for him because i was a miserable
mess and
like i said being married is a really
difficult transition
yeah being married it's hard anyway it's
being yeah and in and of itself and then
when you're miserable
um and i knew in the back of my mind
that i was gonna have to move and so
after a year i did ironically my boss
in cleveland moved to dallas and
she wanted to hire me and so i had to
move to dallas
which was great which meant he had to
move to death which meant he stayed in
cleveland so then our second year of
marriage we commuted
and then how'd that conversation go i
know and how'd it go when you said
like what did he think when you said i
want to go to dallas i know
well on our third date i had warned him
a little bit
i i said don't call me back unless you
want to move to new york city
eventually because that's where i'm
going and you know i was
in my i wish i had your confidence i'm
like where do you live i'll move there
i've moved for so many i mean i'm always
the one to move which has caused me my
own pain but
but good for you yeah well i was old
enough at that point that
you know i was like ready to stand up i
guess for wait old enough how old were
you
i was 31 okay well i'm 37 and i'm still
moving
yeah well i mean everyone listen i'm not
saying that people should do necessarily
yeah i did but i knew that that's where
i wanted to be
and luckily he said that's where i want
to be he didn't realize that we were
going to go to dallas in between
so he eventually um moved there but it
was
the second year was really hard because
this was before like this was still when
you had to have the saturday night stay
to get the airfare that was
reasonable um you're probably again too
young to remember this but you had to
have
you had to have a saturday night stay to
get an airfare that was
like under 200 otherwise it was like a
thousand dollars well i was working
weekends so we
couldn't have a saturday night's day if
i was gonna go back
to cleveland so there was there were
times when we didn't see each other for
three
four weeks wow so it was you know it was
it was difficult he eventually came
to dallas and then we were there
together for 10 months and then luckily
i got a job with cbs news in new york
and we both we both went there
so listen failure is
it sucks when it's happening but
i believe that it is essential to
appreciating success
and you know i have had many other
failures in my life
and i'm lucky to have had them
because it makes me appreciate
the glory of finding success you know so
much more
so you work at cbs and what year was
that then
i was there from 2000 to 2005 and my
first assignment
was actually hillary clinton's senate
run in new york city
except that was the same night that bush
and gore were facing off in the
presidential election as you recall
there was something called the haining
chads in florida and so
i was promptly then assigned to cover
gore which meant i had to go to dc
and i pretty much was there for a long
time so then my husband was saying
um i thought we moved to new york and
now you're living in dc
i was like i'm so sorry you know so um
so i covered you know major stories of
national
you know national news when i was at cbs
and international stories too
um and then i was eventually promoted to
do the saturday early show at cbs
which is what i always wanted to do a
morning show yeah what was your ultimate
goal once you started in the tv realm
um i don't even know if politics was
something that you were passionate about
or not but
i i feel like you're quite a
goal-oriented person and
and dreaming into the what things could
be
what was your ultimate goal with tv was
doing a morning show five days a week
politics i got thrown into at my first
job again because i had a female leader
who believed in me
i've had great female and male bosses
but
um and they all pushed me but i think
the most pivotal bosses
were the women and when i was 23 years
old
she said to me you're now the political
reporter and i said i am
and at that time in virginia there
weren't a lot of us
so this was a big deal to be a female
reporter covering the governor
um so i got i got the bug for for
politics
but my real goal was to do a morning
show because it's a compilation
of hard news and soft news and being
able to show your personality
and when i used to send my mom tapes of
my early reporting
tapes videotapes vhs yeah um
and i would send them to her and and she
would call me up and she'd be like
i think you're doing a fine job she said
but i just really wish you could
smile a little more and show your
personality while you're doing tv
and i was like mom i'm covering fires
and triple homicides
yeah she's like i know but you could
still smile a little bit
i was like mom that doesn't work that
way so when i finally got to morning tv
she was like oh now you know now people
can see
that you have a sense of humor and
you're also smart you know covering the
news stories of the day but you can have
fun
and you can even do cooking segments and
so it was a wonderful
you know compilation of of everything
and that's really how i ended up at fox
was because
at cbs i was just doing that one day a
week and being a correspondent
and at fox i was given an opportunity to
do that five days a week
so you know i thought that that was
going to be an amazing experience for me
didn't turn out that way no no um
so it's 2015 what was the what year
what year was it that um
that the sexual harassment was
that i brought my case july 6 2016.
so what was 2015 like let's just go back
to like before that
well here's because you've been there
since then what year did you start with
my sunday night we've been there a while
yes um
yes but the problem is because um
because of the way in which we solve
sexual harassment cases in our society
we silence women through energy and
through settlements so i can't tell you
what it was like
that's the unfortunate consequence well
then we should talk about that because i
um that i don't want to get the ending
forced arbitration for sexual harassment
is that the actual
case like that's the actual mission or
is that just the bill
okay that's the bill so after after um
i filed my lawsuit on july 6 2016 i had
no idea what was going to happen
i mean this was the ultimate
risk of my life and um you know the way
i characterize it was jumping off the
cliff
completely by myself with no safety net
below
i had no idea what to expect from one
minute to the
to the next day to the next week and
i could have never known so many things
that happened
like that they would start an
investigation
wow you know um i knew
on the whole situation you know and that
he my perpetrator would be fired in two
weeks
wow i mean all the discussions with my
attorneys before were like oh they'll
they'll try to save him you know
nothing will happen to him and everyone
will malign you for sure which did
happen
so there were a lot of things that
turned out for the positive that i could
have never
predicted and then you know
15 months later the whole harvey
weinstein situation and the whole metoo
movement exploded and then
really the floodgates opened at that
point in time and we we got into this
whole cultural revolution
and i started working on
trying to make it better for women all
across our country almost immediately
because i started hearing from all of
these women
almost immediately after i filed my case
and i realized then that this is a
pervasive epidemic
i didn't know that when i filed my case
because when you do something like this
you're so alone
and you're made to feel like it's only
happening to you
and what i came to find out was that it
crosses
every socio-economic line in every
profession so i was hearing from members
of our military
police officers firefighters teachers
lawyers
airline mechanics wall street bankers of
course
other journalists it was everywhere
and the scary thing was that almost all
the stories were eerily similar
in the sense that i finally found the
courage to came to come forward and i
was promptly blacklisted demoted
and fired and the majority of these
women
99 of them that reached out to me by the
thousands have
never worked in their chosen profession
ever again and that's outrageous
and that's when i knew that i had to do
something to change it
so with arbitration which i can relate
to this scenario
i had my own situation with a race team
where they weren't paying me correctly
and i was asking for
documents and questioning things they
weren't giving me what i wanted
so in my contract it says it's for start
it's arbitration is the only way you can
go through things
if you want to hand have a lawyer
involved and
i got to arbitration because there's all
kinds of steps before right it can end
in mediation
um you know there's steps before but we
went all the way to the
end which is arbitration and i was on a
five-year gag
where i couldn't talk about any of the
stuff that happened and what they did
and how much money they didn't pay me
and and the thing was i won i actually
won i
i mean when you get when you take into
account the legal fees
i you know won a little bit
but i still essentially won and
it's just a horrible process where
they and then there's i learned another
term which is like split the baby
which is where basically like an
arbitrator will just kind of like ah
you kind of won but nobody really lost
right nobody really
because i mean i was going for trouble
damages and being treated like an
employee but i was an independent
contractor
there was all kinds of layers to it but
i had to go through arbitration and then
i couldn't talk about it at all right
so you're gagged and this is the way in
which companies have decided to solve
harassment issues because they can cover
up all their dirty laundry
because it's a secret process as a
company you'd want arbitration because
of course
anything that happens you know nobody
would know because the only reason you'd
have to be go to
any uh court or is if you did something
wrong right
so a couple of points arbitration was
never intended to be used in this way
it was to settle small little disputes
that arise in the workplace
and so to suddenly move
like discrimination and harassment and
assault
into this secret chamber was not the
intent when the supreme court ruled on
this more than 20 years ago
so that's the first problem and and the
second issue is that people don't
understand what they're signing when
they sign their employment contract
sure you know as a as a highly educated
woman i didn't
understand what that clause meant and
you add into that that when people start
new jobs they don't expect to get into
disputes of course not
like i know i didn't like did i ever
think this was gonna
be on my resume for the rest of my life
like i'm gonna suddenly become one of
the poster children for harassment in
the workplace
i mean it's not something i aspired to
but
so there's all these things working
against you when you when you find out
you have an arbitration clause that's a
dark day
and i remember the day my lawyers said
to me this is a dark day for you
because you don't have a case anymore
and i said what do you mean
he said because nobody's ever going to
know about this and danica you and i
would not be having this conversation
right now
had my lawyers not figured out a
strategy
that exposed a loophole for them to be
able to sue my perpetrator
personally instead of fox news wow
so that is the way in which my case
became public
and why we're even sitting here today
discussing this culture
because it would have never surfaced
because there are
the other common thing that all these
women said to me when they reached out
to me is thank you for being the voice
for the voiceless
because nobody ever heard their voice
people didn't care number one
and number two nobody ever heard their
voice because they were in this secret
chamber
so if you're if you're not forced into
arbitration then the other way we settle
these cases
is settlements and what comes in
settlements
secrecy nda's non-disclosures women can
never tell you anything
so in the last you know couple of weeks
the group of us at fox have
come together the women there who signed
settlements in ndas and we are
demanding to be released from them what
is are you not ever allowed to say
anything
no it's a lifetime gag
so wow people can go read my complaint
and they can see
what my allegations were again because
we were able to make that
public three years ago when i signed my
settlement it was very progressive
because i got a public apology
that never happens and i also was given
the ability to work and talk about this
issue which i have taken to heart and
have done every single day
since good for you if i would have known
that we would have come this far in such
a short period of time
i would have thought long and hard about
signing that nda aspect of it of course
but back then i was already getting this
apology
and you know the ability to work on this
issue
now we only feel it's fair to
go into the next phase of the revolution
which is to release women from these
ndas so that they can finally have a
voice about what exactly happened to
them
that's the only way we're going to solve
this is to continue to have a national
dialogue about it
and give women their voice back i
feel for me with whatever issues going
on with me
i need to either talk about it or be
able to write about it there needs to be
some form of purging
some form of what i would kind of
describe as like an alchemy within you
where you train
where you're able to transform an
emotion and either get it out of you and
try
and make it turn it into something else
and
the fact that you can't say anything
means that all those emotions just sit
in you
and your truth is not told and
how do you heal from that because i'm
helping so many other women
and i'm doing it for them it doesn't you
know
it matters i guess to me because there
are movies and television miniseries
being done on my story and i can't
participate in those
yeah how are they even accurate how are
those they're even accurate they're
they're not potentially so that can be
frustrating and strange
i have to look at it from the big
picture i have to rise above that
and look at it from the big picture and
say
as long as we're having this national
dialogue and we're having movies on this
they would have never done movies on
this three years ago
so as long as we're doing this then
we're helping women
and if even one other woman sees this
movie or mini-series and feels the
courage to come forward then it's worth
it
so i can still do a tremendous amount of
work without being able to say
on september 14th 2005 this happened to
me
in his office okay um it'd be nice
to be able to tell the whole story and
that's why we're fighting for it
but i can continue to do my work and
i'm incredibly optimistic that the
ending arbitration act of sexual
harassment is going to pass
which will give women the
voice that they need to not be forced
into that secret chamber of arbitration
i really feel it's like the final part
of the tipping point of the revolution
because it when you when you leave the
power dynamic like this where you have
the perpetrator with the hand way up
high
because the woman's down here because he
knows she's silenced
right but you suddenly give her a voice
and look what happens
now she's up on the same playing field
and
that changes the entire dynamic within
the workplace
yeah it might even encourage this person
to not sexually harass
to begin right so i think it's
it's a crucial um part of this equation
and by the way my bill is bipartisan
because after covering politics for
almost 30 years i realize that unless it
is bipartisan it's never going to pass
right so the scope is very limited it's
small
it's it's enough for republicans who
tend to not be in favor of this
to to get on board i have a bipartisan
coalition in the house and in the senate
and i remain incredibly optimistic that
we're going to get this done for women
what is the downside to why it wouldn't
be passed
oh gosh we have organizations like the
national retail association
and the chamber of commerce working
against us because
they feel that it will um open up the
floodgates for frivolous lawsuits
but the beauty of my bill is that it's
only about harassment
yeah it's only about harassment so
unless you have stuff to cover up why
are you against it
yeah i agree what
what advice would you have
for women that might be or a man who
might be in a scenario
where they are uncomfortable and
in my mind that's the great question is
what's the line
when is the line crossed and so number
one how do you know
when the line is crossed and then what
is your advice
if you really feel like it has been
so there are two forms of sexual
harassment in the workplace one's pretty
easy to discern it's quid pro quo i've
been hearing a lot about that in the in
the real world
um with politics but it essentially
means you know sleep with me
for the promotion or you're fired um and
you'd be surprised
how much that still goes on that obvious
a woman reached out to me who i included
in my book
who simply asked for a promotion in
radio and
her boss just two years ago asked her to
get up on the desk and spread him
was he joking or like was this a no this
is a real question
and this is that's that is a typical
story that i
hear there's no gray in any of that
that's pretty black and white that's
quid pro quo
the other definition of sexual
harassment is a hostile work environment
and that's where subjectivity comes in
because what i might think is hostile
you might not
so if there's an off-color joke or
there's a
hey you know i really like your boobs in
that dress
we know that's wrong right but some
person might not be offended by that but
but another person might so that's where
the
issue is allowed to become more
difficult because
now you have people saying things like
well i can't even compliment a woman on
her blue dress
and and i say to that no you can still
say
hey i like your hair or i like your
dress nobody's going to sue you over
that
you know it's kind of a cop-out as long
as these
really incredibly horrible things are
still happening and being said to women
i don't think we should worry so much
about the subjective nature of it
because the quid pro quo stuff is going
on every single day
in a ton of workplaces and that's why we
need to continue the national dialogue
about it because
we need to hold people accountable for
this for this kind of behavior
and take away the myths that have
surrounded this and
subjugated women kept them down for so
long where they didn't feel like they
could speak up
because what happens to them when they
do they're promptly
blacklisted demoted and fired and
maligned
so i'm so hopeful to see the progress
that we have
made and i think we've made great
strides in three major areas
when women come forward now they're
actually believed
i mean that's huge
number two um perpetrators are being
held
accountable almost immediately they're
being fired
and the general public is interested in
these stories
that that is huge because when the
public is interested
that means that the media will continue
to cover the stories as well
and i think one of the reasons that the
general public got so pissed off was
that they were like
why didn't we know about these stories
how could these horrible harvey
weinstein
allegations be happening and we didn't
know about it as a society sure
things that seem to be even known in the
community right don't get well known
you're like
what so i bring you full circle to why
we didn't know about it
because we have decided to solve this
issue in secrecy
that's how we've solved it and that's
why the american public didn't know
about it
and they're pissed and they don't want
it for their kids
and they don't want it for their wives
and their sisters and their aunts
so you know that's how this revolution
has steamrolled ahead
and has continued the movement has
continued
i mean there's a there's there's a lot
of progress to be made and there's still
a lot of work to do yeah
but i remain optimistic so to close the
loop on what if you're in the scenario
if oh yes
yeah just what do you do you know you're
the line you established the two
different kinds of sexual harassment
one being far more black and white than
the other one but
of course you know you still can get
that gut feeling
in your stomach of like whoa that was
super inappropriate or like
you've done that four times now and i
don't think you're kidding anymore
yeah you have to stand up so you have to
tell the person because you have to have
it on the record that
that you have told the person that you
don't appreciate that got it behavior
chapter four of my book be fierce is a
whole game plan for women it's a 12
point plan
that's probably the first time that it's
ever been laid out that succinctly for
women
because it's incredibly important that
you have a plan
and i'll just give you the top three
points you have to gather evidence
you know we live in this he said she
said culture and
people can just glom onto you know well
i don't believe her cause she doesn't
have any evidence
well many times in these cases you don't
and so
you have to try and figure out a way
that you can have evidence and if you
can't have
hard evidence you have to then number
two tell somebody that you trust
and in the workplace so that you have a
witness and that you documented that you
told this person on a specific date what
happened to you
and then number three you must document
it
you have to keep a journal keep any kind
of documentation so that you can
you know help to prove your case and
don't go
to complain about it to hr until you
have
all of this all of your ducks in a row
because once you go to complain you
can't go back to do your plan
and i was i would also advocate that you
don't actually even go to hr which is a
whole nother story
right because hr doesn't really work for
you they work for the company
yeah so i advocate for companies to have
an independent ombudsman who looks at
these cases from an independent point of
view
because otherwise you get sucked into
the old school ways of
the way that they've handled these which
is let's get rid of the woman
let's figure out how to get rid of the
troublemaker over here find something
she did just
let's make it go away they don't even
have to do that they can just fun yeah
that's called retaliation and and they
can just fire you for
simply having the courage for coming
forward it's not legal but they do do it
um and they they'll do everything to
save the perpetrator so then get a
lawyer
you need to get a lawyer that is the
financial at least get legal advice
that's number four
yeah um so that you know what you're up
against because every state has
different rules with regard to gathering
evidence sure so in 11 states for
example you can't tape record somebody
without two-party consent
um and it's actually a felony in
california oh wow
so you need to you know know where you
are and what your state laws are that's
good that's
i mean that's just it's calls to action
if you're in that scenario it's one
thing to hear it's another thing to know
what the heck to do next
when you feel like that's you um or go
get your book be fair sin
it will lay it all out and you can
revisit that
um so like i'm getting this feeling
as do i understand that you're ready to
get back into tv that you want to start
being on television again you have been
so i've been doing documentaries for a e
networks on life
okay and i just completed my third one
what are they on um because i'm sensing
something about this whole scenario
and giving a voice to women but anyway
that's just right
first one was a two hour documentary it
was called breaking the silence and it
was on the every woman story of
harassment because i really wanted to
focus on the women that didn't have a
national platform because that's the
majority of the women
so mcdonald's workers firefighters
nursing home workers and so i traveled
all around the country last summer
putting that one together and then i
just did two documentaries
uh one hour documentaries one on this
cult called the nexium cult that was
actually in new york state
and another fierce woman brought them
down to to get her
get her daughter out of the cult and
then i did my last one on the college
admissions scandal
which was incredibly um enlightenment
where can we
see these documentaries they're on video
on demand or they're on the lifetime
tv.com um website or the app
yeah so i feel like it's such an it's
such a fantastic
i i'm consuming my information
i'll be honest i don't really watch the
news anymore
and i kind of want to ask you about that
in specific but
i get it from documentaries from well
thought through detail-oriented deep
dives
on topics and not just a blurb that
comes out
in 30 seconds on the news in the morning
or the news at night
or something in the newspaper even or
something on social media
that's a fantastic way to really be
thorough about the
about a topic so that's amazing that
you're doing documentaries
do you have plans to do more yeah and i
think that you know it's been really
fascinating for me to go
back into longer form storytelling like
yeah rather than just doing a daily news
show where it's
live is exciting but then you know
you're right it's kind of just like 30
seconds here 30 seconds there and this
gave me the opportunity to really do
that deep dive
but the most important thing about it
was that i could go back to the craft
and passion that i love
and that i have put my time and effort
into
for more than 25 years and to be a
beacon of hope
to work again a beacon of hope for all
those women who have not been able to
return
to their careers and there are thousands
of them maybe more
simply for having the courage to come
forward and so
it was incredibly important to me to be
able to work again
and um and now i'm in the process of
developing
a ton of other television projects uh
from
tv shows to also dramas scripted dramas
that i'm
coming up with and um you know so
really the the world is your oyster or
whatever that phrase is i mean that's
the way i'm looking at it now like i
have so many ideas and
and projects and so i'm pitching them
and uh
so i'm excited what happens that doesn't
even shock me gretchen because you've
done so many different things
to such a high level that um
it's still impressive but um
given your track record it doesn't
surprise me that you're still doing
amazing things um so
one question though well i might have
been a couple but news real quick
so i don't how do we know what to trust
i don't want to watch the news anymore i
don't either and i'm a journalist
so i get it i mean it's
we're in this era of of such hyper
partisan time
that it's just ugly and
i've always been a registered
independent and i feel like
that voice nobody cares about anymore
and it's 43
of the american population 43 of us now
identify as independent
does anyone really want to be all the
way over here or all the way over here
you really kind of want someone in
between anyway
well that's how i i'm not don't tell
that to the to both sides because that's
you know they're vicious about their
their points of view and you know hats
off for having a passion about something
but i think it's doing great harm to our
country because we're focusing on
on both of these extremes and we're
forgetting
all of these people in the middle who
actually might be interested in
compromise and getting stuff done
yeah and at least that's my particular
viewpoint
um i'm a i'm a doer and the idea that we
just sit around and bicker and fight
and not get anything accomplished is not
productive
to me at all and a detriment to our
country
so um i'm with you on not watching the
news and it's quite honestly why
i haven't necessarily missed not being
part of the mix over the last
how has it felt to not really be
so i don't know it i would think you may
lose touch with a little bit a little
bit but it's been kind of liberating
because
you know it was such a a monumental
task every day of every year of every
month to
make sure that you never dropped the
ball and you're always on top of
everything
i've kind of been relieved to not be
covering
this hyper-partisan time but also this
era of fake news
yeah um i have been fortunate enough to
not be labeled as such because i haven't
been doing
a daily news cycle and i think that's
also been tremendously detrimental to
the business of
of journalism i don't know how you get
those people back who actually believe
that outlets that they just don't like
the tone of or the opinion
that they now think that's fake i don't
know how you get those people back
into believing in news and journalism
again well it feels like news is so
one side of the other like you're at
foxy or republican or you're cnn and
you're democrat and it seems like well i
don't even know what to watch what if
i'm in the middle the 43
which is because there's a part of my
life that feels kind of democratic and
there's a part of my life that feels
kind of republican
so where do i watch tv where i'm not
just being what would feel like
brainwashed and i would love if they're
i mean i think it would be fascinating
if there was no party anymore and we
actually had to listen to everyone
we had to listen to what you say and
what you want to do
and where you stand on things and then
it
doesn't it eliminates also the casual
voter or the casual person that just
goes i'm gonna vote for this because
that's
who i am and i'm from here i'm from here
and this is what i vote for you know
it takes away the um
i don't know the the team and it makes
you actually have to listen
and so the people that are going to play
a part and who is
running their state or running your
country will be from someone who's
actually listened
and has a real belief in someone based
on what they've said
not red or blue i'm with you
but until we fund monetarily and
independent party in this country
i'm not so sure that's going to happen
so
you know people who are independents
can't get the the kind of big bucks it
takes to be able to run for office
and so you you kind of have to make that
decision on unless you're already well
known
um in the political arena so
and then you know not to get into the
whole political process but the way in
which we have primaries and all of that
you um you get stuck on the issues
you get stuck on the issues that divide
our parties so
abortion immigration you know some of
the big ones and
people won't come off of those stances
at all
so you're never going to find probably
agreement on that
but i believe there are a lot of other
issues that we could be discussing and i
always like to point to the female
congressional softball team as a good
role model
they play together democrats and
republicans on the same team
okay and what do the men do
they play the democrat team and the
republican team
and i think we need a little bit more
female softball team of congressional
members in our lives
which is to come together
whether or not you agree with anything
that your you know softball mate
thinks or not at least you're showing
compromise by coming together and
playing on the same team and maybe just
maybe
over that practice you might actually
come to compromise on some sort of a
policy as well
at least it's a start be open-minded yes
add a feminine touch to it
yes or just an open-mindedness and
that's just the generalization of the
masculine energy versus the feminine
energy um so if there was one place to
find your news
i mean where do you go what's you what
do you trust the most so my biggest
piece of advice to the american public
is to watch something that you don't
agree with at least one hour a week
great advice and people look at me and
they go oh i can't
i'm like you have to so what i do is i
channel surf now when i have time
i i go from one to the next and it's
been kind of fun because i'm able to see
all the colleagues that i've known for
forever and ever but i actually get to
watch them now
and i have great respect for for so many
of them
but i think it's really important to
watch something that you don't agree
with because
we've gotten really complacent as
americans where we only watch
what we want to hear and how do we then
live and learn and grow and come to a
common understanding with one another
if we're constantly being pummeled with
the same rhetoric
and we don't ever step outside of the
box never mind the social
aspect which is through instagram
twitter facebook
google searches all of that stuff
they're learning
your mannerisms your habits
your preferences all the way down to
what colors you like
and they're just populating you with
more of that so now
not only your things that you don't even
think are feeding into your preferences
you're watching it on tv too just one
thing so i think that's
fantastic advice to watch force yourself
to pay attention to something read
something watch something
that you do not agree with great advice
um what uh
what do you feel like is your
greatest lesson in life so far
uh realizing that you can actually jump
off that cliff and survive
and as scary
as it is and was that
it was worth it and not just for me but
for
all the other women who never had a
voice and for my children
my children were my paramount concern
and
i've seen the gift of courage passed to
them
and that's what keeps me going because
i worried about them a lot and
they both have exhibited
courage well beyond their years as as a
result
and so i know that what i did was worth
it just for my two kids
and i could just like wrap everything up
and say okay i'm done
that that was enough but i know that
it's also helped so many other people
and it you know it really is about
eradicating it for our generation but
for sure for our next generation
once and for all i mean we just have to
get past this we've got to
treat women fairly pay them fairly
promote them
put them in the boardroom and we need
men to help us do that
so it's all about how we
it's all about how we educate our kids
and
more so our boys than our girls and
that's what i've learned it's probably
the biggest lesson
we do a fantastic job of empowering our
girls in fact girls outpace boys in
high school graduation in college
graduation in grades
but we don't tell them the real truth
about what might happen to them when
they get into the workplace that's the
first thing
and with the same amount of importance
we don't focus on our boys to teach them
how to respect girls and women
and that's really the key in this whole
discussion
so if we continue to not pay attention
to our boys we're not going to fix the
problem
we have to get to them at a young age to
get them to respect
their sisters and their mothers and
their aunts the same way in which we
hope that they will eventually respect
their female colleagues in the workplace
that is essential i've spoken to one all
boys school
that's where i should be spending most
of my time
but most of those boys schools for
whatever reason haven't been brave
enough to
broach the subject or bring me in that
to me
is the most important audience
and then to men who currently
control most of the dynamics still in
the workforce most of the fortune 500
companies they're making most of the
decisions
we need them this is not about
mail-bashing this is about reaching out
to them and saying help us
please pay us fairly promote us put us
in the boardroom
because guess what doesn't happen when
you do that
subjugation of women in many forms
including sexual harassment
it's a culture we need a culture shift
yes
and i believe that with your good work
and others who are speaking up about men
and women both
tapping into the strength and the
vulnerability
and the care and the softness and we can
mend these feminine and masculine
energies within
all of us we're one generation away
if done aggressively and right we're
always one generation away from
eliminating an issue
[Music]
yeah we thought we had come a lot
farther on this one than we actually
have
but now that we're talking about it
that's the way we solve it
well let's keep talking yes thank you
for having me danica you're welcome
thank you
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click
on the subscribe button